SOMETHING YOU DIDN'T KNOW BEFOR
BEFORE.
BUT FIRST, DICTATORS IN
TRAINING.
IT THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT, AFTER WATCHING THIS
WEEK SHOW, MANY OF YOU ARE
PROBABLY WONDERING, HOW ON EARTH
THE PARTY OF FDR AND JFK TURNED
SO HARD LEFT SO FAST.
WE SHOWED YOU HOW TO 2020
DEMOCRATIC FIELD HAS BECOME
ESSENTIALLY A PARODY OF ITSELF.
AND EXPOSE THE DRASTIC WORLD
WORLD CONFIDENCE IS FOR AMERICA
IF THEIR TRIP AGENDA IS
EVER ENACTED BUT NOW, TO MOVE
FORWARD, WE NEED TO BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT TO THE LIBERAL ELITE
TEDIOUS REFRAIN ABOUT TRUMP THAT
WE HAVE HEARD AD NAUSEAM FOR
MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
>> Sean: TODAY WE STATED DOWN
TRAVIS QUICKLY AS WE CAN THAT HE
IS NOT A DICTATOR AND HE MUST
OBEY THE CONSTITUTION CREATED >>
USING THE EXACT SAME LANGUAGE
TRUMP USES.
>> HE AND RACES DICTATORS.
>> Laura: THIS IS A CASE STUDY
AND SELF PROJECTION.
IT THEY ACCUSED TRUMP OF
SOMETHING OF WHICH THEY
THEMSELVES ARE ACTUALLY GUILTY.
WELL, TONIGHT WE WILL
IRREFUTABLY DEMONSTRATE THAT
2020 DEMOCRATS LIKE
ELIZABETH WARREN AND
BERNIE SANDERS ARE MUCH MORE
THAN JUST SOCIALIST CRUSADERS.
THEY ARE DICTATORS AND WAITING.
FOLLOWING THEIR IDEAS TO THE
LOGICAL CONCLUSION WE SEE THAT
LIBERALS ARE NO LONGER
DETERMINED TO RAISE YOUR
STANDARD OF LIVING, THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO CONTROL NEARLY
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE.
AND THIS IMPULSE WAS ON FULL
DISPLAY DURING CNN'S MASS ON
CHANGE FORUM.
SEVEN ENDLESS HOURS FILLED WITH
ENOUGH GAFFE TO BURN THROUGH THE
OZONE LAYER.
IT DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
ARROGANTLY TOUTED MULTI-JOINT
ALL HER PLANS AND PROMISED THAT
THE PAIN AND DISCOMFORT THAT WAS
GOING TO COME WOULD BE NECESSARY
FOR PLANETARY HEALTH.
>> THERE WILL BE A TRANSITION.
THERE WILL BE A TRANSITION AND
THERE WILL BE SOME PAIN THERE.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO ASK
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE GOT TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
NOW EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY BE A
LITTLE BIT UNCOMFORTABLE FOR THE
SAKE OF FUTURE GENERATIONS.
>> Laura: A LITTLE BIT
UNCOMFORTABLE.
WELL, YEAH, THE GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO CONTROL HOW AND WHEN
YOU TRAVEL, EVENTUALLY WHERE YOU
SET YOUR THERMOSTAT, ET CETERA.
BUT THEY INSIST OR MORE
ACCURATELY THEY DEMAND THAT
AMERICANS ABANDON ALL NEW
ADVANCES IN DRILLING, AND OIL,
AND GAS EXPLORATION.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION I'M IN
FAVOR OF BANNING TRACKING.
>> BANNING EXTRACTIVE OIL
FRACKING FROM PUBLIC LANDS AND
GOING AFTER DRILLING AND
STOPPING THEM FROM OUR COAST.
>> YOU SAID STOP NEW OIL AND
GAS.
>> Laura: EAT YOU HERE BOOKER.
GOING AFTER THE LICENSES FOR IT
HAS EVER BEEN TO A FRACKING
RIGHT?
I HAVE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A FEW
MINUTES.
THE AVERAGE PRICE OF A GALLON OF
AMERICA TODAY IS ABOUT $2.57.
REALLY GOOD.
I MEAN THAT'S LIKE A TAX CUT ON
EVERY MILE WE DRIVE AND EVERY
PRODUCT THAT WE BUY.
IT'S GREAT NEWS FOR AMERICAN.
BUT AFTER DECADES OF VIOLENCE ON
THE MIDDLE EAST FOR OIL, OUR
NATION IS NOW NEARLY ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
BUT IF DEMOCRATS HAVE THEIR WAY
AND THEY FOLLOW THE U.N.'S LEAD,
ALL AMERICANS TO BE PAYING A
HELL OF A LOT MORE.
AND OF COURSE, THE RICH WOULDN'T
FEEL THAT WITH THOSE GAS PRICES
BECAUSE MIDDLE AMERICA IT WOULD
AT ALL.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
DICTATING ENERGY SOURCES.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DICTATE YOUR
DIET AS WELL.
>> SHOULD AMERICANS CHANGE THEIR
EATING HABITS AND EAT LESS BEEF?
IT'S BECAUSE GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT, IT'S GOOD FOR YOUR
HEALTH IF YOU LIKE ME.
>> THERE HAS TO BE WHAT WE DO IN
TERMS OF CREATING INCENTIVES.
>> WOULD YOU SUPPORT REDUCING
RED MEAT SPECIFICALLY?
>> YES, I WOULD.
>> Laura: DOES SHE HAVE AN
EXERCISE WORKOUT TOO?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
KAMALA HARRIS IS AN ONLY
INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU EAT BUT
HOW YOU DRINK.
>> DO YOU BAN PLASTIC STRAWS?
STICK I THINK WE SHOULD BE
READY.
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO EAT
RING OUT OF THE FAVOR STRAW BUT
LET'S ENCOURAGE INNOVATION AND I
THINK WE COULD DEAL WITH IT BUTW
THINK WE COULD DEAL WITH IT BUTE
THINK WE COULD DEAL WITH IT BUTD
THINK WE COULD DEAL WITH IT BUTO
NEED TO BAN THE PLASTIC.
>> Laura: THIS IS A PAPER
STRAW BY THE WAY AND IT'S HARD
TO DRINK OUT OF.
THE DEMOCRATIC DICTATORS, THEY
DON'T STOP THERE.
THEY WANT TO POLICE YOUR
SOURCES.
>> SHOULD THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
HAVE A SAY IN WHAT KIND OF WHITE
BULBS WE USE?
IT'S BECAUSE YOU KNOW, THEY
POTENTIALLY BURN OUT AND SO IF
ANYTHING WE SHOULD BE PUSHING
REGULATIONS THAT MAKE IT SO ALL
RELATED FIELDS CONSUME LESS
ENERGY AND NEED TO BE REPLACED
LESS OFTEN.
>> Laura: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
ALL OF THE COMMON PEOPLE DOES IT
TAKE TO CHANGE A LIGHT BULB
JOKE?
WE WOULD HAVE THOSE JOKES
ANYMORE.
OKAY, AND IF YOU LOVE HAULING
YOUR KIDS AROUND AND YOU'RE A
CHEVY SUBURBAN ARE TROLLING
AROUND IN YOUR NEW
TOYOTA COROLLA, TOO BAD.
>> WILL EVERYONE HAVE TO DRIVE
ELECTRIC CARS?
STICK ABOUT MY PLAN BY 2045 WE
WILL HAVE BASICALLY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES ONLY.
>> THERE WILL STILL BE SOME
LEGACY GAS GUZZLERS ON THE ROAD
FOR QUITE SOME TIME BUT YOU WERE
GOING TO OFFER TO BUY THE
CLUNKER BACK AND HELP THEM
UPGRADE.
>> Laura: CLUNKER?
HE'S OBVIOUSLY NOT DRIVEN A
REALLY AWESOME EIGHT CYLINDER
VEHICLE.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
A BUYBACK BY THE WAY?
WHERE A VENDOR THAT ONE BEFORE?
WE'RE GOING TO GET ALL THE MONEY
TO BUY THESE THINGS BACK.
OF COURSE THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE
COME TO EXPECT FROM THE NEW AND
IMPROVED DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BECAUSE THE HAPPIER YOU ARE IN
YOUR EIGHT CYLINDER SEDAN
ENJOYING AND IN-N-OUT BURGER
WITH MORE MONEY IN YOUR POCKET
THE MORE MISERABLE THEY ARE.
BECAUSE THESE DEMOCRATIC CONTROL
FREAKS, THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
BE INDEPENDENT.
THEY WANT YOU TO BE DEPENDENT ON
THE CRUMBS THAT THE GOVERNMENT
DOLES OUT.
AND I THINK OF ALL OF THIS THE
MOST SHOCKING REVELATION LAST
NIGHT CAME FROM BERNIE SANDERS.
MORE THAN JUST DICTATING YOUR
TRANSPORTATION NEAR HOME
LIGHTING, THEY WILL EVENTUALLY
SEEK TO CONTROL HOW MANY
CHILDREN YOU HAVE.
>> HUMAN POPULATION GROWTH HAS
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE PAST 50
YEARS.
THE PLANET CANNOT SUSTAIN THIS
GROWTH.
WOULD YOU BE COURAGEOUS ENOUGH
TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE?
>> THE ANSWER IS YES AND THE
MONKS CUSTODY AGREEMENT WHICH
DENIES AMERICAN AID TO THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
THAT ALLOW WOMEN TO HAVE ABORTIO
THAT ALLOW WOMEN TO HAVE ABORTIS
THAT ALLOW WOMEN TO HAVE ABORTIR
EVEN GET INVOLVED AND
BIRTH CONTROL TO ME IS TOTALLY
ABSURD.
SO I THINK ESPECIALLY IN POOR
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD WHERE
WOMEN DO NOT NECESSARILY WANT TO
HAVE LARGE NUMBERS OF BABIES,
SOMETHING I VERY, VERY STRONGLY
THE PORT.
AT >> Laura: STATE PLAN
FAMILIES, MODIFIED ONE CHILD
POLICY, GOT IT.
WHILE PERHAPS BERNIE CAN ROLL
OUT HIS OWN ONE CHILD POLICY
THAT WILL MAKE THE CHINESE PROU
PROUD.
REMEMBER, IT'S ALL FOR THE GOOD
OF THE PLANET.
NO SACRIFICE IS TOO GREAT AS
LONG AS IT'S MOSTLY ON THE
SHOULDERS OF THE POOR AND THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
AND LIBERALS HAVE THE GOAL AFTER
EVERYTHING WE'VE HEARD THIS WEEK
ON THE ANGLE, THEY HAVE THE GOAL
TO CALL TRUMP A TYRANT.
THESE ARE THE MOST CONTROLLING
PEOPLE ON THE FACE OF THE
PLANET.
AS LONG AS THEY ARE MAKING ALL
THE DECISIONS.
SO BY ELECTING ANYONE OF THESE
TOP-TIER DEMOCRATS, YOU WOULD BE
RELINQUISHING YOUR CHOICES, YOUR
RIGHT TO DETERMINE YOUR OWN
DESTINY.